[Music]
[Music]
so
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
so marius
at last i find you
yes
yes now
how i recognize you
i should have known you traveled in the
skies
there
they're always watching
i've been searching for you for a long
time marius
i was rather beginning to think you
didn't want to be found
oh forgive me tyrion please
it
wasn't my fault
not your fault tell me malice how was it
not your fault
the wanderer
yes
it was
was the wanderer
my days at the rogue citadel seemed so
long ago
i sought refuge
from my memories in the company of other
outcasts behind the mountains past the
eastern gate
[Music]
oh i fought sleep
for days at a time
for when i dreamt
the memories
would return
memories of the monastery
i couldn't tell the difference anymore
and the evil from my dreams
followed me at my heels
how had he found me here
how could this broken shell of a man
barely able to carry the weight of his
own sword
be the burning terror
which drove me to hide here
he seemed to
to have demons of his own
he struggled to contain
he was losing
so
[Music]
as i watched
i became convinced
that i was
[Music]
how else could i explain them
were these the demons from my dream war
were they born
within the wonder
so
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
why did i follow him
i don't know
why do things happen as they do in
dreams
all i know is that when he beckoned
i had to follow him but from that moment
we travel together east
always
into the east
[Music]
[Music]
we traveled east
over the mountains and into the vast
deserts of broken lands
[Music]
as the days passed my companion told me
of himself
that he had once been a great warrior
and that a dark and sacred burden
now
weighed heavily upon him
we traveled for an eternity across that
aran wasteland how long
i couldn't say
and always
a dark cloud seemed to follow us
just over the horizon
finally the journey ended we climbed the
last bridge
there below us lay
[Music]
with a great sea beyond
made camp that last night
perhaps it was the warm desert wind or
the sound of the ocean but for the first
time in many weeks
i slept
however
the dreams returned but these were
clearly not my own i beheld the vision
of a great man the mage tell russia you
were there too material i remember
seeing you in my dream
his brethren had cornered a great demon
a veil of the lord of destruction who
had been set loose upon the world
and they attempted to imprison the demon
within a sacred stone
yet whether attempts failed
tarasha selflessly volunteered to
contain the demon within himself
completing the prison
he instructed his brethren to find him
within a tomb
buried under the sand and there to
wrestle with the demon
now you know what i seek marius
this is my brother
sleep now
we set out with the dawn
the next morning we walked over the hill
toward
luke colleen
i had no idea then
of the horrors that were in store for me
there
you